[音楽]
n ame
こんにちは
私はですね日本で唯一
プロで阿波踊りをやっている宝船というグループで活動しております
現在はですね年間250ステージ
1年間で10カ国ぐらいですねアメリカもヨーロッパもアジアも回って阿波踊りを発信
する仕事をしております
今でこそこんなに毎日のように阿波踊りを取っている仕事を選んでやってるんです
けれども
子供の頃から
あ踊りが大好きだったかというと違ってむしろ真逆だったんですね
僕が阿波踊りに出会ったのは父親の影響です
徳島県出身の
父親が a 0
僕をですね無理やり兄弟を無理やりあを橇に連れ込みまして
僕は東京で生まれたんですけれども小学校1年生の頃から青でやっています
4年生の頃この写真のように宝船が出来ました
もう
僕が青戸やるかやらないかという選択肢はなく親がやると言ったからやる
どう思ってたかというと僕は
あ踊りは恥ずかしいものだってずっと思ってました
皆さん
小学校の頃例えばかっこいいなぁと思っていたスポーツとか習い事って何だった
でしょうか
サッカーつがバスケットボール野球
運動神経が良い人はモテる僕は阿波踊りを習ってたんですね
もちろんそれを友達に言うのが恥ずかしくてしょうがなかった
笑われるんじゃないか人と違うことがカッコ悪いことだ際ことだとずっと思ってました
転機が訪れるのはもっとずっと後です20代になって2011年
ハワイで阿波踊りを取らないかというオファーをいただくことになりました
その時に初めて海外のオファーが来たので皆さん
あのメンバーもですねテンションが上がっていこうとなったんですけど
そのいこうという気持ちは僕は英語を全く出来なかったし
海外で観光地にわざわざ行ってを取る価値がまだあんまり見出せてなかった
そんな時にハワイに行ってそのを取る前日に日本では
大震災が起こるんですよ
これが僕はハワイで経験して次の翌日
ハワイは津波とかは一応大丈夫だった
いろいろ大変だったんですけど大丈夫でフェスティバルが開催することになった
僕らは練習してきた踊りをただただ一生懸命踊るだけ
その時にですね僕らが意図してない反応が返ってくるわけです
すごく日本のニュースを聞いて不安だった
気持ちがもやがかかっていてこれからどうしようかと思っていた日本人の方ハワイに
住む日本人の方だったり
ハワイに住む外国の方だったりその方々が
勇気をもらった
元気出たよありがとうってすごく言ってくれたんですよ
これはタイミングだと思います僕らが意図してそれをやったか違います
タイミングとして僕らが披露したものが
海の向こうに喜ぶ人がいるんだということを意図しないタイミングで知ったんですね
で僕は周りにずっと阿波踊りが言えなかったけれどもそういう客観的に自分の育った
場所じゃないところでそういう反応が返ってくることによってもしかしたら恥ずかしい
のは芸能ではなく自分の芸能への情思い込みが恥ずかしいと思っているんじゃないかと
思ったん
ですよ
そこから僕は阿波踊りをアップデートしようと思いました
きっと青どれの中には歴史が続いてきた意味がありまして
魅力もあるはずでもそれは今の時代から離れていってしまって
伝統っていうのは実は常に今を繰り返し
風を入れながら続いてバトンを次世代に渡すもうなのになぜか古いものとして保存され
てしまう
じゃ僕らが僕らの今の感覚で青での先進を
もっと発信できないかソースと俄然ですね
今までダサい格好悪い古くさいと思ってた踊りが輝くように見えてきたということです
ね
3つありますどこが阿波踊りが面白いのか
日本文化なんで面白いのかまずですね
言葉の関係ない国に行きます宗教も思想も違います何でつながるかというと非言語で
つながるんですね
リズムで
これがあれば
感情表現それからどんな思いで立ってるか踊りで共有できる
そして
いろんな人種の人がいます考え方も違います
今ではほとんどの問題社会問題とは対立軸が生まれてしまうもので社会ものが起きて
しまうけれども踊りって答え正解がないですから
たように楽しめる好きな楽しみ方でいいし好きな解釈でいいただ9分以下 p
であればいい
これが大手の魅力2つ目最後はですね
一緒に阿波踊りというのはお祭りですから
芸能というクオリティのあの鑑賞する
それから
踊りを取るこういう垣根を作るようなものではなく子どもから大人まで楽しめるお祭り
なんですね
このお祭りというのはインターラクティブで
楽しめる子どももいてもいいおじいちゃんがいてもいいデートで着ててもいい
白人も黒人もどなたでも大丈夫一緒に楽しもうよ
これがを待つの基本なんですよ多くのエンターテイメントっていうのはクオリティの
レベルを競い合うことが21世紀型だと思われておりましたが今ではどうですか
体験型
一緒に楽しんでつながるものというのがどんどんどんどん社会的に価値があると思われ
てきている
ですね僕らは
この阿波おどり有名な言葉がありまして
踊る阿呆に見る阿呆同じ阿呆なら踊らにゃ損損
これはつまりうまいとかヘタとか関係ないよ
恥ずかしさの向こう側行こうよ
これなんですよ思い出してみると僕はどうだったか
子供の時恥ずかしさから出れない子供だった
客観的に外の世界に
強引にでも出ていくことによって初めて自分の価値を知った
と言う
人だったんですが
このはず会社の向こう側に入って踊る阿呆になる人がいつの時代も世界をつくっている
と僕は今感じてます
例えばビジネス例えばエンターテーメント例えば何かの研究
すべてそうです誰もやってないこと誰か大きな実績を作ることを成功することは人が
やってないこと
をやるということであって踊る阿呆になることなんですね
今日は僕らはですね例えば dj の人とコラボしたり
単独公演をしたりそれからこのようにプレゼンテーションで王道の魅力を発信したり
いろんなことしてますが実際何よりもですね見ていただくのが早いので
この僕の話が終わった後実際皆さんに阿波踊りを体験してみていただき
ますその時ぜひですね皆さんも
その大濃度で構いませんのでインタラクティブに手拍子をし対戦をしたり立ち上がっ
たり好きなやり方で楽しんでください
そしてこの答えのない
言語化できない楽しみとか勇気みたいなものを自分の人生に置き換えて何かの活力にし
ていただけたらこの僕らがここに立った意味があるのかなと思っておりますそれでは
続きまして阿波踊りパフォーマンスをさせていただきますよろしくお願い致します
[拍手]
うん
[音楽]
ううっ
ぶー品
ぴょん
ん
[音楽]
はぁ
ブーフファロ
持っている
[音楽]
ん
ran
んだ
ん
[音楽]
ええええええん
いいいいいい
eme
くん
分
ん
1分
[音楽]
tanu ぼん
ん
[音楽]
ウーファー
ていた
うん
うんうんんん
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
うんうん
んんん
ん web
[音楽]
うん
うわぁ
8位
ん
[音楽]
すっごいはぁ
ん
うざ
持っています
いいいいいい
ん
[音楽]
pandan
ん
んふふ
[音楽]
ブーブー
ぐうっ
うん
ん
[音楽]
うんうん
ん
[音楽]
うふん
いうんルール
[音楽]
web
ウーファー
info
[音楽]
dj ん
1件
info
voodoo
ううっうぅううん
4日
分
入っていません
re 本文
ん
うん
[音楽]
うつ
ブーフ
ん
[音楽]
えっ
ニャー
[音楽]
[拍手]
a 僕たち打つか前にヨーロッパ各はから帰ってまいりました
ヨーロッパの時間でとただいまたぶん夜だと思いますみなさんこんならー
[音楽]
本月ああ
皆様の心の中に潜む阿波踊りとくだらない固定が移転は
部行っとらせでやって針はしたん
[音楽]
まぁどーう
5点中からねぇこのイベントに参加させていただいて
まあいろんな方のプレゼンテーションを目指していただきました
もうね皆さん本当にね頭が良くて
もうかっちょいいー小菅イケてる
最高でじゃあ
まああの僕もねせっかくこういう
なんかかっこいいねと出てるんだから頭よさげなこと言いたいなーとかと思って色々
隠れて考えたんですけれども僕はあんまりそういうの向いてないんでいつも通りやって
もいいですか
おや勝手ながら
[拍手]
ん
a子だけいうことはないのだ
ば母になるって最高でるよねー
ミラだ空カー好きだいとれ月っていうとき
bahco で触れてしますかー
多分
ポッキーにはギリギリのところで人はー
爆破にならなきゃいけないと思いませんやー
をゲー今ねービデオ撮影されてるわけですよ
youtube でなんか中継されたりしてるんでしょの掘ったりするでしょ
youtube をご覧の皆様こんにちは誰か楽だけど
あんたがダガー皆様 youtube の奥で見てる皆様に支えたいと思います
あなたがにはパチパチやってるその機会でを味わえない可能
ここでをやって金だ
皆さんもそうですよねーポジと youtube で確認できればそれで十分なあった
のにわざわざ家を飛び出してここまでやってきた
皆さんは投資だと思えば際ぎゃー
ん
をゲーそうと日までは youtube の惨がれ右へつけてやりましょうよ
こっちの王が最高だってことだ
みるとば bar 響になる準備はできてますかー
バカになる準備はできてますかー
[拍手]
そうと決まればぜひになっちゃいましょうサンダープレイ
あげー
[音楽]
この中に一人も頭いい奴をいるけどバカになれば厄介ナーザ
は彼がい
わかりますがいい
言いたいことわかりますよねー
時までわーわーください続いて
ワーキな声出してみてください宜しくお願い致します
いきますよ
んさーやーいいとわー
イエーイとバーン
ワッド章伍選べますよねー
[音楽]
アートね水だけ
ジャイああああああ
ああああああ
あああああ
おーん
ん
goo
ああああああ
マヤとやどやどやだ
エアどやどやとやなん
浅田
[音楽]
yeah
やだやだやん
mar
def
[音楽]
の
うーん
[拍手]
ん
ありがとうございましたーーー
[拍手]